LOGAN ROY: Bullshit!
Boar on the floor.
(SCOFFS)
LOGAN: Hey!
(CHUCKLES) Okay.
It's a game.
In the corner, over there.
Stand there. Go, go, go, go, go!
(KARL LAUGHS)
Ah.
LOGAN: All right.
(EXHALES)
Tom.
-Me?
-LOGAN: Yeah.
-Uh, Pierce?
Um...
Well, there's a lot of...
(CLEARS THROAT)
...factors, and...
But... yes, I--
Personally, I like it.
-Ah.
-I like it.
Boar on the floor, over there.
Gerri, stand up.
Stand up!
-Pierce?
-The fuck are we doing--
Couldn't tell you. Don't know.
-Have you played it before?
-No.
GERRI KELLMAN: Well...
(CLEARS THROAT) ...actually, I--
(HESITATES)
To be perfectly honest,
I've-- I've had a few doubts.
LOGAN: Honesty.
You see?
Everybody, do you see?
Honesty.
Greg, stand up.
(GRUNTS)
Did you get any orders
from my brother,
the fucking conscience
of the prairies?
-Me?
-LOGAN: Yeah.
Uh-- I...
don't... uh...
Yeah, I could-- I th--
I've had so-- some doubts too.
Oh? Fucking doubter. Over there.
But the rules
are that you're spared
if you tell the truth--
-LOGAN: Oh--
-And I just told you the truth.
Oh, there are rules?
-GREG HIRSCH: Right--
-Do you know something, Greg?
There are no fucking rules.
(WHISPERS)
Over there.
GREG: Okay.
(CHUCKLES NERVOUSLY)
-(ROMAN ROY SNICKERING)
-LOGAN: Roman.
I like it for real, Dad.
-I wanna help--
-Stand the fuck up.
Um, okay.
Kendall took a call
from the biographer.
We all got a call, Rome.
ROMAN ROY:
Okay, yes. But you see--
He seemed like he wanted
to actually talk to her.
To smoke you out for Dad.
What? Fuck you. Why'd you get
to smoke me out?
I'm smoking you out.
Why don't you tell us
about your mystery call?
Oh, the phone call?
Uh, yeah, it was Frank.
He meant to call you.
He wants to know
if the plan to overthrow Dad
is still happening.
Someone spiked Pierce.
Which one of you boars did it?
Tom!
-Yes?
-Sit on the floor.
It's fun.
-Seriously?
-Yeah, it's a game,
"Boar on The Floor."
-TOM WAMBSGANS:
I really-- I feel--
-LOGAN: Get down!
Boar on the floor.
Kendall, ring the troops.
ALL: (CHANTING)
Boar on the floor.
-TOM: Guys--
-ALL: Boar on the floor!
-LOGAN: Karl, get down.
-Come on.
-Greg, on the floor, boar.
-ALL: Boar on the floor!
Boar on the floor!
-LOGAN: Come on, Frank!
-(ALL CONTINUE CHANTING)
Boar on the floor!
-Frank.
-Why am I in this?
How the fuck
would I know, Greg?
You think I have
a rational explanation for this?
-Frank?
-(CHANTING CONTINUES)
Feed the piggies,
guest of honor!
That's it. Boar on the floor!
Boar on the floor!
Oink for your sausages, piggies.
Shh. Shh. Shh.
Oink for your sausages,
piggy.
-Oink! Oink!
-KARL: Oh, Jesus Christ--
-Oink for your sausages, Tom.
-KARL: Oink.
-LOGAN: Oink.
-Oink. (SNORTS)
LOGAN: No. No.
No half-hearted oink.
I want full-hearted oinks.
-TOM: I'm not doing it.
-KARL: Oink, oink, oink, oink!
LOGAN: On the count of three,
the last piggy
to eat a sausage is the mole.
That doesn't seem like
a very good system.
Who spoke to Pantsil?
GREG: (WHISPERS) Please.
LOGAN: Hey!
Crawl in a circle
and close your eyes.
-(LAUGHTER)
-LOGAN: Three... Greg, oink!
(GREG SNORTING)
Two...
-TOM AND KARL: Oink, oink,
oink, oink...
-ROMAN: Here we go!
One.
(CHEERING AND LAUGHING)
-Eat the sausage, Tom!
-TOM: I got it. I got it!
(LAUGHTER AND SHOUTING
CONTINUES)
-TOM: I got it. I got it.
-It's a close call.
TOM: It's my fucking sausage.
(CROWD JEERING)
-TOM: Karl stole my sausage!
-(KARL CHEERING SPITEFULLY)
-Karl stole my sausage.
-ROMAN: It was on the count!
Too effin' slow.
I'll get you your booby prize.
Eat up, piggies!
ROMAN: I believe he said,
"Eat up, piggies."
I want to see
you little piggy fucks eat.
-KENDALL ROY: Come on.
-ROMAN: Eat it.
-Indemnification, fucking dummy.
-What-- Are you fucking serious?
How old are you? Give me back
my fucking phone.
-No, what are you hiding?
-What are you-- What--
Hiding nothing.
-Give me back my fucking phone--
-What's your code?
Are you fucking serious?
My code? Um, my code is...
-um, fuck you--
-Face lock.
-What?
-KENDALL: Hold still.
-ROMAN: Get the fuck away!
-(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
ROMAN: You know fucking--
Fuck you, dick.
Okay you got it. All right?
Are you happy?
There's nothing in there.